opposers this can't wait now don't
listen to the fake news media who will
say Paul Ryan's not running for
reelection because he has no chance of
winning or because he's a soulless
ideologue dedicated to taking healthcare
away from poor people no there's
something else going on here
something huge this is an opposition
exclusive Paul Ryan is not running for
reelection because of a medical
emergency
I've somewhat legally obtained his chest
x-ray and I am going to show it to you
right now this is not easy to look at
it's upsetting and if there's any kids
in the room have them look away Paul
Ryan has no spine it's tragic and
actually it's not as rare as you might
think
especially in Washington it's a
condition called cowards back name for
Rowan coward who first developed the
condition in the 1800s after years of
stealing medicine from the orphanages
around Ireland to give to the wealthiest
1% but don't feel bad for the speaker
America because Paul Ryan is going out
doing the thing he does best deciding
not to do something so stay strong Paul
you truly are a spineless cowards back
sufferer the fight continues good you
hid down here with a real truth lies you
want to help me defeat the globalists
and stay on the inside click and
subscribe and help me defeat them
because following me on my youtube
channel makes you a leader it tracks
trust me